ça y est nous y sommes docteur strange 2
est enfin sorti et je suis très heureux
je sens que l'on veut en parler
longtemps car c'est le genre de film
même s'il ya des petits mystères autour
de l'intrigué de l'histoire des
personnages etc le film est tellement
fourni avec le multivers qu'on parcourt
et caetera et bien c'est genre de film
qui est bourré de tout petit détail qui
peut sembler pas important au premier
abord mais qui pourtant ce sont des
détails qui vont être importants et qui
vont pouvoir amener des éléments pour la
suite bref qu'est ce qu'on l'aura
attendu ce film on faisait déjà des
théories dessus en 2019 ma toute
première vidéo marvel c'était un trois
théories sur doctor strange où on
parlait déjà de la suite et cetera c'est
bref c'est fou qu'est ce que le temps
avance bon arrêtons un peu de
tergiverser on a du boulot bienvenue
dans cette première vidéo dédiée à
doctor strange 2 et oui j'ai bien dit
première car franchement il ya plein de
choses à dire déjà bien évidemment la
vidéo va spoy le docteur strange
multiverse of madness donc je vous
conseille bien évidemment d'aller le
voir avant de voir cette vidéo et puis
surtout cette vidéo va servir avant tout
de mise au point et d'explications il y
a eu énormément de théories sur le film
il ya beaucoup d'éléments a expliqué on
va quand même faire quelques petites
théorie mais voilà cette vidéo sert déjà
avant tout de mise au point sachant
qu'en plus j'ai vu le film qu'une fois
pour le moment donc voilà premièrement
je pense que nous pourrons faire le
point concernant wendat et effectivement
au rwanda était le plus gros point
d'interrogation du film et bon sang
qu'est-ce qu'elle est badass enfin nous
avons fait face à la wild a que nous
attendions tous on en a beaucoup parlé
mais rwanda est clairement l'héroïne qui
a le plus souffert entre la mort de ses
parents de pietro de vision et les
événements du x avec la disparition de
ses enfants c'était clairement le coup
de grâce cela faisait un moment qu'on se
demandait quand est-ce que wendat allait
craquer surtout que désormais elle a le
pouvoir elle a pris conscience qu'elle
est la scarlet witch et à être désormais
épouser ce rôle néanmoins au fond de moi
j'étais vraiment
est-ce qu'ils vont oser le faire est-ce
qu'ils vont vraiment nous proposer au
rwanda en tant que méchante car après
tout bandar est une avengers c'est une
bonne personne normalement bon il ya eu
l'excusé du dark pool mais des fois on
doute quand même pas mal sur la capacité
de marvel studios peut-être par peur
d'aller trop loin je me souviendrai
toujours de la série law qui avec
l'arrivée de gang personne n'y croyait
en étaient tous là mais non c'est
impossible c'est beaucoup trop tôt mais
en même temps le temps passe et bah faut
bien avancer au bout d'un moment quoi
bon et du coup toujours concernant au
rwanda ils ont amené beaucoup d'éléments
intéressants dont on reparlera à
l'avenir déjà le mont one d'accord
depuis luanda vision je vous en parlais
personnellement je me disais qu'elle y
était déjà vu que sa cabane était au
milieu d'une chaîne de montagne au final
ils ont un peu modifié la chose pour le
récit est sincèrement c'était très cool
le monde d'accord apporte plein de
nouveaux éléments pour l'univers du mc
pour bien expliquer ce qu'est ce lieu
pour celles et ceux qui ne connaîtraient
pas en gros une dague or est l'endroit
où octobre est normalement enfermés dans
les comics en tout cas c'est là bas
qu'il va écrire et concevoir le dard
gold et c'est également là bas ou au
rwanda et n'étonne en profitera alors
pour la marque et par le biais de sa
magie et cela va lui permettre de
revenir dans le futur et pour celles et
ceux qui ne connaissent pas que taunton
fait partie de ce qu'on appelle les
grands anciens des sorte d'entité majeur
qui existe depuis l'aube des temps ce
dernier a étudié énormément les mystères
de l'univers tous les trucs mystique et
du coup il est devenu par la suite le
tout premier match noire de l'univers il
est le dieu du chaos celui qui a créé la
magie du chaos que possède wendat et ça
c'est pareil je suis tellement heureux
on en a fait beaucoup parlé à l'époque
deux tonnes et la désormais bas
légitimé dans le mc ou gong en a parlé
d'ailleurs les quatre titans qui
accompagne au rwanda quand elle est à
wind d'abord ce sont des créatures à
l'éffigie doc tonnes bref c'est
exactement ce que je vous disais au
début on à l'intrigué du film son
histoire mais dans la profondeur le film
apporte et légitime énormément
d'éléments des comics qui passent pour
des détails dans le film tone & win
dagor sont désormais légitimé et je peux
vous assurer que l'on ne va pas en
rester là c'est quelque chose que marvel
adorent faire et c'est normal car cela
permet de tizé des éléments pour les
prochaines productions mais on a
toujours des petites infos caché par ci
par là des petites phrases qui au
premier abord ne semble pas importante
mais qu'ils le sont par exemple dans
infinity ward tony par l'état peppers de
leur mariage et que dans un rêve il
avait une petite fille du nom de morgan
sur le moment c'est une information un
peu nul 1 1 et on s'en fout un peu mais
au final c'est vraiment arrivé dans une
game par la suite dans loin de la vision
agata nous attisé luanda que la scarlet
witch possédait un pouvoir dépassant
celle des sorciers suprême et qu'elle
était vouée à détruire le monde est bien
longue et strange se sont bien fait
défoncer il ne pouvait rien faire et
rwanda a bien failli faire une
catastrophe bref tout ça pour dire que
la mention dr on ne me la fait pas c'est
pas quelque chose d'anodin et là nous
pouvons tenter pourquoi pas de faire une
petite théorie bien évidemment je suis
partisan que wang dan n'est pas tout à
fait morte fin que ce n'est pas si
simple que ça on va dire wendat a encore
beaucoup à nous proposer c'est un
personnage devenu clairement important
et ce serait étonnant que cela s'arrête
là déjà on sait qu elizabeth olsen
l'actrice de rwanda a normalement signer
pour encore plusieurs années il était
même fait mention d'un projet solo la
concernant donc voilà mais du coup
qu'est ce qu'il se passe pour rwanda
après dr strange 2 et bien je vous avoue
qu'en sortant du cinéma j'ai eu deux
idées qui me sont venues soit scellier
actn rwanda étant un peu l'avatar doc
tonnes sont héritières en tant que
scarlet witch et vu qu'il a été annoncé
cela ne m'étonnerait pas que tonnes
permettent le retour du rwanda du style
en détruisant route d'agde or elle à
liberec tonnes ou genre c'est lui qui va
la ramener à la vie ou qu'elle atterrit
dans sa dimension etc etc mais les deux
ont une liaison importante dans les
comics il ya tout un arc ou wendat etc
tonnes cherche à prendre le dessus sur
l'un et sur l'autre vu que quand on veut
se servir du cor de ouandda pour revenir
il pourrait y avoir un délire comme ça
et cela permettrait d'avoir un projet
foule solo pour cette dernière ou bien
mon autre idée qui est un petit peu
farfelue mais que je trouve quand même
plutôt légitime est bien c'est que cela
annonce l'arrivée de méphisto je sais
que beaucoup en ont marre de ce
personnage que tout le monde voit
partout mais pour une fois je pense que
cela pourrait clairement être possible
pourquoi j'ai pensé à mes fils tôt et
bien c'est un peu en rapport avec les
comics évidemment comme on l'a vu dans
le film les enfants de wendat sont
devenus la priorité de cette dernière
elle veut les retrouver sachant que les
enfants du rwanda sont des héros connus
de l'univers marvel est qu'ils sont
désormais dans le mc hugh je me dis que
c'est bizarre que ça s'arrête là we can
et speed sont des héros plutôt populaire
et pour moi ils seront adaptés dans le
mc eu quand ils seront adultes
mais pour ça bah faut qu'il revienne eh
bien je me dis pourquoi pas rwanda en
décédant finirait dans la dimension de
méphisto pareil pour celles et ceux qui
ne connaissent pas le protagoniste
méphisto c'est un peu la représentation
du diable c'est un être extra
dimensionnelle qui vit dans un endroit
qu'il appelle l'enfer et ce dernier est
toujours constamment en recherche de
nouvelles âmes et caetera et dans les
comics ce dernier est pas mal lié à
wendat car quand cette dernière va
donner naissance à ses enfants par le
biais de ses pouvoirs ces derniers à un
moment donné lui seront retirés et il
nous sera révélé qu'ils étaient en fait
des fragments d'âme de méphisto ce qui
va conduire au rwanda et les autres
avengers a voyagé jusqu'à la dimension
de méphisto personnellement je me dis
que cela pourrait être pourquoi pas
adapté surtout que wendat est la scarlet
witch méphisto pourrait clairement être
intéressé par l'âme de cette dernière
bref c'est une idée comme ça bon dans
tous les cas au rwanda a clôturé tout ce
qui était darko auld et cetera le livre
de vie jaunty et autres voilà ces
artefacts c'est terminé les verra plus
c'est juste pour faire le point et on va
peut-être parler des illuminati
maintenant je pense que c'est
possiblement une déception pour certains
mais en vrai c'était sûr que ça allait
se passer comme ça en fait les
illuminati du mc us sont des héros du
multivers qui ne sont pas du tout
attachés à notre réalité en plus de cela
ils sont composés de tête que nous
reverrons à l'avenir chez nous donc il
ne faut pas que le spectateur s'attache
à des êtres d'autres univers qui seront
adaptés en production dans notre réalité
la réalité principal que nous suivons
quoi je prends le cas de monsieur
fantastique j'étais comme un dingue de
voir reid richard's mais nous savons que
nous allons avoir un film quatre
fantastiques dans l'avenir du mc eu avec
notre reid richard's donc autant éviter
les confusions dès maintenant pareil on
a déjà une captain marvel on a déjà
notre captain america déjà que pour
beaucoup le mc us est plutôt dur à
suivre car il commence à y avoir
énormément de production bas je ne vous
dis pas le délire si en plus de suivre
nos héros il faut suivre l'histoire des
road autre univers on l'avait cole mais
les illuminati c'était sûr qu'ils
allaient être tuer comme ça cela nous
permettait de voir l'étendue du pouvoir
de wendat et à quel point elle peut être
dangereuse par contre je ne vous cache
pas que les illuminati c'est une
dinguerie dans le fond car pareil c'est
comme on le dit depuis le début mais ce
sont les petits détails que l'on pense
pas très important qui en fait tissent
des trucs de ouf je vous le dis
sincèrement je ne croyais pas du tout à
la présence de black bolt dans le film
tout simplement car j'étais en mode
banon ils vont pas oser c'est too much
et pourtant ils l'ont fait et c'est un
détail que je trouve vraiment ouf car
oui légitime et black bolt dans un autre
univers cela sous-entend que nous avons
nous aussi notre black bolt et par
conséquent c'est amener tout le délire d
inhumain et cetera et c'est pareil pour
charles xavier avec les mutants c'est
légitimer les mutants dans le mc eu et
par conséquent annoncé que la réalité
que nous suivons peut aussi avoir ses
mutants à l'avenir bon et bien
évidemment je ne vous dis pas le nombre
de détails cachés qu'il doit y avoir
quand strange et america chavez change
de réalité mais bon sincèrement là il
faudra attendre la vod histoire de voir
tout ça en détail néanmoins je tiens
quand même à le souligner et je pense
que vous êtes beaucoup aussi à l'avoir
remarqué c'est la présence du tribunal
vivent j'avais commencé à écrire une
vidéo théorie sur ce dernier car il ya
pas mal de choses à dire le concernant
dans le mc eu mais bon je l'avais mise
de côté donc voilà si cela vous
intéresse je pourrais pourquoi pas
essayer de la reprendre mais voilà le
tribunal vivent il a déjà été pas mal
teasé dans l'eau qui bien évidemment
mais au final il y a toujours des liens
entre cette entité et strange le
tribunal vivent est mentionné dans
strange un il est encore là dans strange
2 et puis on oublie pas la scène
supprimer d'in fi nit ivoire ou strange
devait donner une vision à thanos du
tribunal vivent en bref c'est encore un
délire de fou ce bond et enfin
concernant dr strange lui même les
bandes-annonces nous ont bien manipuler
comme il fallait et tant de choses se
sont avérées fausses pas de nightmare
pas de shu magot race etc le défendeur
strange qui meurt dès le début le
sinistre strange qui est très différent
de ce que l'on pensait bref d'ailleurs
ils nous ont même fait croire que
strange aurait de nouveau la pire du
temps alors que ce n'était pas du tout
le cas c'est quelque chose dont on a
beaucoup parlé dans de précédentes
vidéos mais il fallait résoudre l'arc
amoureux entre strange et christine
palmer ces derniers ne seront jamais
ensemble leur relation est trop
compliqué notamment à cause du fait que
stephen est un super héros est un super
héros un peu spéciale on ne va pas se
mentir et surtout cela fait longtemps
qu'on théorisé là-dessus mais je vous ai
toujours dit qu'il fallait clore la
liaison amoureuse entre strange et
palmer comme ça marvel pourrait nous
introduire cléa à l'écran et ils l'ont
fait et oui c'est elle que nous voyons
dans la scène post générique du film
cléa vient de débarquer pour notre plus
grand plaisir et annonce un nouvel arc
de fou pour le docteur pour faire simple
clé à est la femme de doctor strange
dans les comics sauf que leur relation
est un peu compliquée pourquoi me
direz-vous et bien tout simplement car
cléa et la nièce de dormammu oui oui
dormammu
énorme entité malfaisante seniors de la
dimension noir et que strange affronte
dans doctor strange 1 je ne vais pas
vous mentir que les relations familiales
ne sont pas simples concernant le
docteur et du coup c'est pour ça que
nous retrouvons la dimension noir quand
cléa ouvre une brèche à la fin du film
c'est parce qu'elle provient de là bas
en groupe dormammu et l'un si ce n'est
le plus grand ennemi de doctor strange
dans les comics ce dernier n'est pas
mort à la fin de doctor strange 1 et
encore heureux car dormammu c'est un
sacré morceau à faire tomber donc voilà
on pouvait s'y attendre à ce que nous
leur verrions un jour ou l'autre
d'ailleurs cela va même peut-être
servira à ramener notre mort d'eau qui
avait été teasé à la fin de doctor
strange un quart dans les comics
bordeaux devenu le baron mort d'eau
s'alliera à plusieurs reprises avec
dormammu pour faire tomber strange mais
bref on aura tout le temps qu'il faut
pour faire des théories concernant tout
ça à l'avenir pour le moment on fait le
point et on tente d'expliquer le film
moi je vous avoue que mon point noir
c'est le troisième oeil de doctor
strange je pense que c'est l'un des
éléments qui cache le plus de mystère et
dont il y aura beaucoup matière à faire
des théories en fait ce qui est
particulier c'est que le film se termine
sur l'arrivée du troisième oeil sur le
front de strange comme si c'était une
souffrance ou une sorte de malédiction
puis dans la scène post générique
ce dernier semble l'avoir assimilé et du
coup cela nous tease clairement un
nouveau pouvoir au même titre que
l'arrivée de claire la signification de
cet oeil est importante car dans la
symbolique avoir un troisième oeil
signifie voire mieux voir plus de choses
que si tu n'en avait que deux avoir un
troisième oeil c'est signifier que
doctor strange pourrait voir des choses
que les autres ne voient pas et ce
nouveau pouvoir va nous permettre de
faire évoluer le docteur est d'amener un
nouvel aspect magique encore inconnue
dans le but de renouveler le personnage
et tout ce qui s'ensuit et c'est dans
les comics il n'est pas si rare de voir
strange avec un troisième oeil sur le
front mais le truc c'est que c'est lié à
l'oeil d'agde à moto qui est un artefact
qui symbolise le troisième oeil de
strange et haga moto bon voilà on sait
que nous sommes sur des artefacts
bienveillant tandis que là dans le film
cela ne semble pas être un si bon
présage que ça non plus car à l'origine
c'est le sinister strange qui a amené la
thématique du troisième oeil il se
pourrait que ce 3ème oeil soit une
marque de quelque chose de malveillant
après tout strange a violé plusieurs
fois les lois naturelles il a utilisé le
dark old il a effectué un rêve
passerelles et les esprits lui ont fait
comprendre que ce qu'il faisait bas
c'était clairement interdite le
troisième oeil pourrait donc être un
nouveau pouvoir mais issu d'une
profanation comme une marque pour
montrer que doctor strange est quelqu'un
qui a fait des dingueries c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs la preuve pour dire
qu'il est surveillé et signalé que c'est
lui l'auteur de l'incursion soit que
deux univers entre en collision si je ne
dis pas de bêtises ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que le sinister strange
possédait ce troisième oeil et il était
lui aussi à l'origine de l'incursion qui
a détruit son univers donc voilà et
concernant america chavez je vous avoue
ne pas avoir grand chose à dire le
personnage était cool et respecte à fond
les comics on retrouve les mêmes
pouvoirs les mêmes portail en forme des
toiles et on retrouve également
l'origine story avec ses deux mères si
ce n'est que la différence c'est qu'ici
america a déclenché sa séparation avec
ces mères mais dans tous les cas c'est
sûr qu'elles ne sont pas mortes strange
le dit lui même et ce n'est pas un
hasard quand elle maîtrisera ses
pouvoirs elle ira les chercher
pour écouter je pense que nous allons
arriver à la fin de cette vidéo je suis
trop peureux là de pouvoir débriefer de
doctor strange de avec vous c'est
difficile à réaliser que ça y est le
film est enfin sorti et que du coup on
va pouvoir théorisé analyser ce dernier
etc je comprends le fait que certains
soit un petit peu perdues en nous
ça va pas trop où nous nous dirigeons
mais vraiment c'est quelque chose qui ne
m'étonne pas tant que ça le mc lui s'est
clôturée avec endgame une conclusion des
trois premières phases du marvel
cinématiques unis versent et maintenant
il faut relancer la machine c'est comme
si nous étions de nouveau dans la face
une tout se remet en place aux quatre
coins de l'univers et à terme tous se
réunira mais oui cela prend du temps et
surtout que cette fois ci il y à déjà
dayraut qui ont déjà leur histoire qu'il
faut continuer en plus des nouveaux
héros introduit en tout cas moi j'ai
adoré docteur strange de je l'attendais
depuis beaucoup trop longtemps et voilà
je suis juste content compter sur moi
pour vous faire de belles théories bien
évidemment on va reparler de ce dernier
donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour
ne pas louper les prochaines vidéos et
d'ailleurs j'aimerais beaucoup faire un
live pourquoi pas avec vous pour parler
de doctor strange 2-1 live sur twitter
du coup bien évidemment au moment où je
tourne je ne sais pas trop quand est ce
que ça pourrait se faire et dites moi si
cela vous intéresserait mais voilà je
vous mettrai plus d'infos en commentaire
épinglé quand la vidéo sera sorti donc
n'hésitez pas à voir et puis n'hésitez
pas aussi à me suivre sur twitter et
instagram pour avoir plus d'informations
et c'est surtout ce qui concerne la
chaîne n'oubliez pas le petit pouce
bleus le petit commentaire aussi sur ce
que vous avez pensé du film je suis
curieux de savoir votre avis et puis
voilà écouter bas c'était argot rock que
la layan garde soit avec vous allez ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]